[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
en direct sur tv soixante dix huit sur
facebook sur les réseaux sociaux pour
fêter un anniversaire
l'anniversaire du lancement c'était il
ya exactement un an le 24 janvier 2021
de l'ue vs cus sat grâce à la fusée
space x alors on va revenir sur ce
lancement de ce nano satellites qui
s'inscrit évidemment donc peut-être dans
une nouvelle conquête spatiale mais
aussi sur ses objectifs c'est à dire
mieux comprendre les causes du
réchauffement climatique grâce aux
observations très précise du fait de ben
et puis aussi de trouver les moyens
d'aider plus efficaces pour agir on va
évoquer aussi les perspectives ouvertes
par ce lancement dans les années qui
viennent et peut-être annoncé le
lancement d'un futur nanosatellites ça
devrait se passer dans un an on va en
parler avec vous philippe quelques scuds
bonjour vous êtes fugitive aussi un
directeur du du latmos vous êtes tous
secours travaillent toujours la noce
vous est aussi vice-président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et mustapha masta bonjour vous êtes
astrophysiciens vous êtes le responsable
de la filière stratégique du latmos
et puis nous rejoindrons tout à l'heure
des gens qui ont participé à ce premier
lancement comme pierre louis caso qu'il
est du radio club de 50 ans divine car
les radios amateurs ont participé à
cette cette mission et puis deux
industriels jean-paul carta decarta
rouxel et benjamin azou les deux hold
comme alors qui participera probablement
au prochain lancement on va parler tout
à l'heure peut-être d'abord
on va revenir à ce lancement c'était
était donc il ya un nom on regarde quand
même les images
143 satellite viennent d'être mis en
orbite le plus grand nombre de
satellites jamais envoyé en une seule
fois parmi eux deux satellites du latmos
dont un sous pavillon français lui vécu
ça tu sais une certaine fierté parce que
du coup c'est toutes les équipes qui
sont concernés tous les laboratoires
toute l'université nos tutelles le cnrs
nous deux universités voilà qu'ils nous
ont aidés ou une fois que là je le
faisais par là c'est là où la tension
est la plus grande parce que c'est là où
tout peut arriver pour notre satie le
lancement a lieu à 16 heures heure de
paris une heure plus tard le nano
satellites uvs q7 était en orbite la
mission a franchi les étapes critiques
coût global de la mission 3 millions
d'euros
elle avoue stone est évidemment de ce
jour l'argent et l'autre qui veut qui
leur parlait c'était quoi votre état
d'esprit d'abord il faut raconter il y
avait il y avait des problèmes un peu de
météo qui fait que le lancement a été
reporté 1 alors oui le lancement c'est
quelque chose de très complexe et
particuliers initialement devait partir
en décembre 2020 puis pour des raisons
techniques le lancement était décalée
donc les premiers problèmes sont liés au
fait que deux satellites ont été éjectés
par erreur du lanceur avant le lancement
donc la compagnie space x a dû faire des
aménagements et des modifications à la
place ils ont rajouté 10 satellites
starlink ensuite la prochaine date de
lancement était prévu le 10 janvier mai
2021 et pour des raisons météo on a eu
un décalage une première fois une
deuxième fois une troisième fois pour
partir un 24 janvier 2021 et c'était
assez c'est très stressant oui alors
c'était la fusée sp6 est alors qu'ils
comportaient évidemment me beaucoup
d'autres satellites 1 bah oui c'est là
c'est un record en plus 143 satellite
regardent de différentes tailles donc
qu'il faut éjecter et c'est là aussi où
il ya une prouesse technique côté
lanceur c'est qu'il faut les éjectés
sans qui ce choc les uns contre les
autres donc il ya quand même une
problématique est compliquée oui et
qu'elle est quel était votre état
d'esprit là quand vous avez partir cette
fusée
on a déjà développé une multitude
d'instruments donc c'est quelque chose
que l'on connaît bon un moment on savait
la fusion il ya toujours une émotion et
une inquiétude on a vraiment peur que ça
un moment notamment quand la poussée
maximum de la fusée arrive c'est là où
c'est le plus dangereux donc c'est
vraiment stressant ensuite l'autre
paramètre clé comme expliqué philippe
c'est que lorsque vous avez cent
quarante trois satellites qui vont être
injectés 1 avec des petites en
différents les uns après les autres il
va falloir nous qu'on communique
rapidement avec le satellite et qu'on
retrouve notre note satellite 1 donc
c'est toute la difficulté c'est à un
moment aussi de savoir où on se situe en
orbite et comment communiquer avec le
satellite ce qu'il faut dire voilà c'est
que ce lancement c'est de
l'aboutissement d'un long travail du
latmos l'un basse et c'est là où
effectivement il y avait quand même de
la tension effectivement mais mais aussi
un peu de soulagement puisque finalement
une fois qu'on est au lancement c'est
plus nous qui sommes maintenant que
c'est
justement là l'entraînement il a duré
longtemps parce qu'il a fait quand même
un certain nombre d'années qu'on est sur
cette problématique de se dire
qu'effectivement ce ce type de deux de
ces deux plateformes peut-être utile
scientifiquement
et donc haye c'est l'aboutissement de
beaucoup de réflexion beaucoup de
discussions beaucoup de voix là de de
travail avec les partenaires avec tout
le monde pour finalement voir voir voir
l'objet partir donc c'est quand même
beaucoup d'excitation alors quand je dis
de long travail est d'abord un travail
scientifique il faut maîtriser les
chaînes de du spatial
alors comment ça se passe voilà c'est
alors la particularité aussi c'est que
dans notre cas de figure on démarre avec
une feuille blanche il faut il faut
pousser une idée donc nous ce qui nous
intéresse évidemment ces deux mesures et
des variables climatiques essentielles
parce que notre côté on considère que
les activités humaines sont directement
responsables du réchauffement climatique
lorsqu'on appelle par activités humaines
sur les gaz à effet de serre qui sont
elles liées par tout ce qui est associé
à la combustion d'énergies fossiles et
aussi usage des terres et la
déforestation donc l'objectif initial
pour nous c'est de faire de la recherche
pas forcément de fabriquer un satellite
et on va s'intéresser notamment aussi à
la mesure de la réflexion des seuls
l'albédo les puces les poussières ça
c'est clair vis-à-vis de nos objectifs
scientifiques et dans la préparation
pour qu'ensuite on converge vers la
réalisation donc d'un premier satellite
de a à z où on va développer toutes les
chaînes c'est à dire que là où on a fait
quelque chose de très bien voilà
exactement on a une vue d'une maquette
du satellite qui a été mis en orbite
on a développé toutes les chaînes de a à
z toutes les réalisations une seule
brique nous manque un présent c'est la
mise en orbite d'un satellite mais c'est
à brice d'autres élèves d'où l'appel
space x nous l'amour est une société où
d'entreprises qui nous permet de mettre
en orbite un satellite mais
que go coûte quand est-ce que ça a été
décidé cette mission 20 et combien de
temps ça a pris au fond moi c'est
toujours difficile hein on va dire que
ça germait dans nos têtes depuis un
certain temps on va dire que ça a pris
dix ans soit disant parce que disons que
dix ans de manière concrète ou le
premier projet est sorti 1,6 appelé
serbe le premier projet si je me
souviens bien et après a fallu
convaincre les uns les autres et trouver
le moyen de le faire alors en fait
on a eu beaucoup de difficulté à trouver
et à convaincre au début donc il ya
manque données inde il faut qu'on se
jette à l'eau et cognac et donc voilà
c'est comme ça que ça peut commencer oui
parce qu'il ya un travail scientifique
il ya aussi un travail économique enfin
fo fo le financement faut des infos des
aides fondés et ça c'est un gros gros
boulot parce que c'est vrai que parfois
peut-être on peut se demander pourquoi
des universitaires veulent lancer un un
satellite il ya eu cette interrogation
je suppose
il ya cette interrogation en fait cet
acteur gassion bon elle et elle et elle
est facile à répondre au départ parce
que la première question c'est celle que
mustapha a donné ses sections
typiquement il ya des besoins d'observer
la terre et on y reviendra après notre
vraie question était comment l'on fait
pour l'observer avec un temps de
revisite plus grand parce que les
phénomènes bouge beaucoup là on le voit
on a un grand volcan katanga qui en
train d'exploser
bon ben on a besoin tous les jours
d'information où en est le nuage houssin
au sérieux jusqu'à quelle attitude c'est
parti donc donc on prend toutes les
données donc il ya déjà beaucoup de
choses qui existent dans l'espace mais
c'est vrai que on aime bien avoir la
même variable revu plusieurs fois et là
il faut des constellations de cette
époque du coup la démarche de petits
satellites venait aussi en lien avec
l'agglo kolelas pronostic de
constellation donc là que la question
scientifique elle était assez clair pour
nous bien évidemment après on est
universitaire donc on a aussi une
demande d'aidé des étudiants de se
former aussi les docks de 2,2 et de se
former aussi aux technologies de demain
et aux dispositifs de demain donc c'est
là aussi où on a mis en place des
formations ad-hoc pour pour pour
permettre aux étudiants de nous
rejoindre sur ses projets et il faut
dire que là je sais pas ce qu'on appelle
la nano nisation enfin en tout cas la
miniaturisation 1
ça correspond bien au fond avec la
capacité d'innovation des chercheurs
n'ont alors oui exactement ça correspond
à cette capacité d'innovation mais aussi
bon pour déjà rebondir sur votre
première question l'idée où on s'est dit
on va foncer en 2016 un moment on était
allé aux états unis on en a discuté avec
nos collègues notamment qui travaillent
sur des activités scientifiques
similaires aulas donc boulder dans le
colorado
et là on a vu qu'on avait un retard donc
le lien avec la miniaturisation l'a
clairement vu c'est à dire que on voyait
apparaître de plus en plus des
technologies qui était plus en plus
petite et la question que l'on s'est
posée c'est quel type de science on
allait pouvoir réaliser avec des
éléments miniaturisés et un autre
paramètre clé par rapport à la
miniaturisation et à d'autres effets
c'est qu'on a vu émerger
le new space donc mis nu space sont des
nouveaux acteurs qui arrivent dans le
domaine et qui vont à un moment briser
les approches classiques donc
typiquement à la fin des années au
milieu des années 2000 quand notamment
ce pays 6 arrive et dit je vais mettre
en orbite lancé un indice positif je
vais récupérer mes étage beaucoup n'ont
pas cru à cela donc l'arrivée du new
space la miniaturisation et une
multitude de paramètres font que on a dû
aussi être en phase avec
la société avec la situation actuelle
donc il fallait aller vite il fallait
l'éviter et il a fallu et ça c était
aussi une démarche nouvelle pour pour
l'université passé des accords entre le
public et le privé oui alors là
l'originalité alors d'une part je
reviens un poste dans le dire que le
digital est important ça c'est un petit
c'est compliqué mais mais mais ça reste
du coup un coup beaucoup moins cher et
abordable un coût pour une université
alors ça d'ailleurs été beaucoup
développée par les universités
américaines qui en ont déjà envoyé un
certain nombre c'est ce que c'est
mustapha on est on est très très en
retard côté français sur ces petits
satellites
et c'est eux qui ont inventé aussi le
standard de cubes soit c'est à dire que
du coup on standardise donc on facilite
l'envoi dans l'espace on facilite les
dispositifs qui peuvent être réutilisés
dès lors que ces instants dame
donc nous on sait qu'on a utilisé ce
standard là
et
la difficulté était effectivement en
même temps de faire progresser les
questions scientifiques
c'est vrai que les chercheurs ont
toujours beaucoup de mal à s'arrêter sur
une idée on est on peut toujours faire
mieux nos contrées mais c'est dur mais
il fallait aller vite allez quand même
arrêté assez rapidement les choses et
puis
on avait trouvé les partenaires donc on
connait on va les voir tout à l'heure on
a trouvé les partenaires et puis fallait
trouver des financements et les
financements c'est pas des très gros
financements mais ça reste qu'il faut
trouver et donc on a des sponsors des
partenaires et donc le financement c'est
un peu l'origine et du montage c'est que
le financement s'est fait en même temps
que le développement ce qui d'habitude
est un peu différent on a le financement
et on fait le satellite là nous on a un
petit peu fait les deux en même temps
mustapha métalleux
au fond la mission scientifique des du
satelis tes dires l'observation du
réchauffement climatique en coin ça a
été décidé dès le début sans fin on
était dès le début parce que d'aider la
fin des années 2000 nous ont travaillé
sur des thématiques en lien avec donc
tout ce qui est relation soleil climat
on sait que depuis la fin du 19e siècle
jusqu'au milieu des années 2010 la
température moyenne de la terre elle a
augmenté d'environ 1,1 degré celsius ce
qui n'est pas du tout négligeable
les concentrations en or car en dioxyde
de carbone en méthane protoxyde d'azoté
n'ont jamais été aussi élevé depuis plus
de deux millions d'années donc il ya
beaucoup de paramètres qui font que nous
savons que nous devons utiliser ces
technologies nous devons utiliser les
petits satellites ou les gros satellites
1 parce qu'il ya deux types de missions
nous on s'intéresse évidemment 2 pour
pouvoir observer la terre trouver des
solutions et agir alors évidemment au
niveau climatique si on ne fait rien on
peut avoir des augmentations température
d'au moins 4 1 5° c gysi du d'ici à 2100
et ses critiques les dénommés énorme
donc on peut aussi avoir des points de
bascule parce que un petit pic membres
comme j'expliquais on s'intéresse à la
levée de l'albédo c'est la réflexion de
la lumière une manière et donc on peut
avoir une modification de la structure
des sols aussi on observe de la
déforestation donc tous ces paramètres
font que nous sommes en sursis
l'intérêt de l'observation spatiale
c'est de pouvoir mesurer de tout temps
on a pas d'alternance jour nuit et tous
points comme explicite par an ce qui
veut dire alors on reviendra après sur
ce qu'on a appris depuis a nommé c'est
vrai que grâce à ce nano satellites
voilà vous savez tout ce qui se passe
pour le temps
et partout c'est alors cela nous a dit
c'est un démonstrateur technologique
dans un premier temps on regarde et on
valide des technologies pour faire des
mesures et on sait que un seul satellite
ne répond pas besoin pour pouvoir faire
une observation en orbite basse ce
satellite est à 600 kilomètres
d'altitude environ donc à 600 kilomètres
d'altitude pour pouvoir fabriquer une
cartographie de rayonnement de la terre
il nous faut environ une vingtaine de
jours et nous notre besoin c'est
d'arriver à avoir des résolution
temporelle c'est à dire savoir ce qui se
passe tous les trois heures il y avoir
des résolution spatiale de l'ordre de
200 km la seule façon d'y parvenir c'est
d'avoir au moins une cinquantaine de
satellites là tout l'intérêt pour nous
justement c'est de pouvoir le valider
avec ses petites technologies et aussi
de s'appuyer sur le territoire les
entreprises locales pour faire en sorte
que l'on puisse faire émerger sur ce
genre de technologie avec des
entreprises de proximité et on va voir
que voilà il va y avoir d'autres ça dit
il voit dans cette fac c'est ça fait
partie de vos projets parmi les acteurs
qui ont participé à cette un succès deux
satellites alors ça peut surprendre il
ya notamment les radios amateurs là je
propose de voir un petit magnéto qui
donne l'idée voilà deux des gens qui ont
participé en dehors d'une atmosphère on
va cueillir pierre-louis caso une charge
utile radio amateur sera intégrée à
bordes inspired at elle sera destinée à
tous les radioamateurs de la planète
haderer lisse et le latmos ont décidé de
concevoir une carte complète de
télémétrie bidirectionnelle libre pour
les cubes sat ce dispositif sera associé
au transpondeur audio déjà validé à bord
du vs cussac et qui offre déjà une
possibilité de communication entre
radioamateurs
la mission inspired 7 s'inscrit dans un
programme spatial de coopération
internationale des initiatives de
sensibilisation et des actions
pédagogiques sont mises en oeuvre auprès
des établissements scolaires du
département des yvelines et dans les
milieux associatifs
le but est de susciter des vocations
auprès des plus jeunes la mission
inspired cet est composée d'académique
de partenaires industriels et
d'étudiants de discipline et d'horizons
divers alors là on parle déjà d'une
espèce est mais cette coopération elle a
existé dès le début avec avec levesque
soit bien au gazon dont vous êtes vous
êtes membre du du radio amateur de 50
ans du roi du club de 52,50 a
commencé d'abord qu'est-ce que c'est un
radio amateur à côté de vous et vous
commencez nié ces faits ce lien avec le
latmos on rénovateurs c'est quelqu'un
qui s'intéresse à la radio et qui un
jour décident de passer à l'émission
radio pour expérimenter sur les diverses
fréquences et demande à sa son
gouvernement à son état l'autorisation
de faire de la radio pour cela il veut
pas passer un examen va recevoir une
licence qui est l'autorisation d'émettre
et un indicatif radio internationale
haut niveau donc là cette activité
existe depuis à peu près 100 ans donc au
départ dans les années 1920 c'était des
chercheurs qui voulaient à leur propre
compte pour leur propre compte faire de
l'expérimentation et puis
progressivement on a attribué à ce
service de radiocommunication le service
amateurs un ensemble de bandes de
fréquences et aujourd'hui nous disposons
de 25 bandes de fréquences qui s'étale
deux des centaines de kilos a sauté au
giga hertz et donc on a un spectre
radioélectrique attribué qui est très
très large le plus large de tous les
services de radiocommunication qui est
assez peu utilisées évidemment puisque
nous sommes trois millions de radio
amateur
diane 400 mille en france et environ 15
en europe pardon et 15000 en france
alors le satellite est équipé des scot
qu'on appelle un transpondeur 1,16 à le
satellite est équipé d'une carte radio 1
pour assurer les communications entre le
sol et le satellite pour le contrôler
pour envoyer des données est également
ce cette carte radio permet une fonction
transpondeur c'est-à-dire au nez mais
vers le taux de 30 satellites et ça
redescend sur terre à un autre endroit
c'était quoi votre mission va à la
mesure des radioamateurs dans cette
danse est
vous les concurrents satellite vous avez
besoin de communiquer avec lui lorsqu'il
sera là où il est et donc vous avez deux
grandes solutions soit vous faites appel
à une entreprise de comme ballet sumatra
où d'autres entreprises ou
télécommunications qui vont vous fournir
pour un montant relativement élevé une
prestation de l'attribution de
fréquences de systèmes radio de
logiciels ou bien si vous budget sont un
peu en dessous vous chercher d'autres
solutions est une solution c'est de
faire appel ou radio ça veut dire de
placer le satellite et ses
communications dans le cadre des
activités radio des radioamateurs et je
crois qu'il ya des secteurs les dates
pose d'ailleurs qui ont passé le diplôme
de radioamateurs ses amis tout à fait
alors je vous en avez en face
s'il avait fait partie là donc donc des
radioamateurs donc nous avons un
indicatif donc typiquement je m'appelle
f4 xo émond est mon ami l'acf 5 ned et n
est donc on a un indicatif f pour france
moi j'aurais tendance à ajouter par
rapport aux radios amateurs ce qui nous
a intéressés c'est pas un problème -
coût économique c'est plus du savoir
faire et de l'expérience c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où il ya un radio
club amateur à proximité nous on a
besoin de rentrer en contact avec eux
pour avoir une maîtrise de la chaîne ce
que ce que nous avons appris au niveau
scientifique c'est que lorsqu'un
satellite est mis en orbite on a aussi
ce qu'on appelle une phase de recette en
voile on va faire une multitude de tests
sur le satellite et scientifiquement
parfois on peut avoir des spécifications
molle on peut ne pas maîtriser tous les
paramètres et tout l'enjeu c'est de
pouvoir communiquer avec le satellite
pouvoir modifier les opérations
à partir du moment où on maîtrise la
chaîne radio communication on peut faire
ce que l'on souhaite aux satellites et
ça c'est un paramètre clé pour nous on
l'a testé alors pour les demandes de
fréquences et de l'attribution nous on
passe moins il ya évidemment des
demandes auprès dia et rue pour en
parler c'est la structure internationale
nagra international amateur radio
réunion c'est la structure qui nous
représente auprès de l'union
internationale des télécommunications
d'accord et donc dans cette structure y
avait eu il ya eu un petit groupe de 14
personnes qui attribue des fréquences
radio à des satellites dont ce sont des
projets de satellites et donc depuis une
vingtaine d'années 15 ans il ya à peu
près 600 satellites qui ont bénéficié de
fréquences radio amateur donc ils se
sont placés dans le cadre radio amateur
et leurs opérateurs ont passé l'examen
d'en parler mustapha pour être pour
avoir le droit réglementaire
d'émettre et de recevoir et donc cette
structure a attribué à au satellite une
excuse at 2 fréquences qui sont contre
437 0,20 et 145 906 demandons qu on
aimait à sa quarante cinq mégahertz on
reçoit autour de 437 mégahertz alors
ensuite l'autre paramètre c'est que nous
le satellite et affiliés en france donc
c'est un satellite français vise pour
cela qu'on travaille avec le cnes
l'agencé spatiale française pour pouvoir
respecter la législation française il ya
ce qu'on appelle la loi des opérations
spatiales on peut pas se permettre de
lancer n'importe quoi on doit respecter
des règles et on doit un moment mettre
en oeuvre une stratégie de désorbitation
et côté émissions les réceptions de
donner aussi à un moment le cnes va nous
donner aussi un numéro de déclaration ça
remonte à genève au niveau de
l'organisme international de gestion des
fréquences parce que typiquement on a eu
un moment un retour de modification de
notre fréquence parce qu'on aimait t on
en avait une bande de fréquences qui
était trop proche d'un satellite
allemand de mémoires mais il peut y
avoir comme ça des wings est embêtant
oui c'est très embêtant alors on a aussi
discuté cno nos amis radio amateur et
donc vont s'ouvrir a ajouté que en fait
les radioamateurs ça fait donc que
plusieurs décennies qui s'intéresse aux
satellites et donc dans chaque grille il
ya une structure radio amateur qui
s'appelle amsata msa t et donc il ya un
chat sam sat allemagne awsat uk et c est
donc cette structure a fortement
participé en même temps que le avec le
radio club de saint quentin en yvelines
à la mission à la définition du système
radio et notamment côté logiciel je
confirme donc il ya aussi à un moment
parce que ce que l'on reçoit c'est un
signal audio donc il faut transformer un
signal audio en données et ensuite la
donner il faut la transformer en
produits scientifiques donc pour aller
d'une réception de signal jusqu'à un
produit scientifique il ya énormément de
travail donc on a évidemment un travail
avec al sadd francophones qui se passe
très très bien et ensuite actuellement
pour la prochaine mission qui s'appelle
un super sat 7 nous sommes en train de
fabriquer une nouvelle antenne îlots
réception de données parce que au delà
de la constellation de satellites c'est
à dire avoir plusieurs satellites en
orbite il nous faut aussi des zones de
réception seul et là il ya une
particularité c'est que la france est
présente sur cinq continents donc ça
nous permet de disposer potentiellement
de lieu géographique pour pouvoir
installer des antennes et faire de la
réception de données multiples
absolument c'est quand même une pardon
je vais juste rajouter un mois parce que
effectivement la collaboration avec les
radioamateurs est aussi et il ya aussi
un côté très intéressant c'est le côté
pédagogique dire que c'est un monde qui
est quand même très ouvert et donc du
coup ça permet aussi et on le voilà
maintenant dans le nouveau master on a
des intervenants du du radio club pour
justement à prendre puisque il faut
passer des licences donc c'est pas c'est
pas de l'approximatif il ya vraiment des
choses à comprendre et à connaître et
donc ce côté pédagogique aussi très
intéressant pour nos étudiants est de
travailler ses fréquences là c'est quand
même une magnifique aventure suppose
pour les radios allumées chacun
progresse dans la connaissance et la
porte ses techniques ses connaissances
scientifiques you combien plusieurs
dizaines de radios amateurs que l'on
participé à l'expérience une dizaine un
peu plus d'un an que la wii puis avec
donc comme sap francophones
donc c'est un projet intéressant à la
fois techniques technologiques
scientifiques les orbites les fréquences
les distances les débits de
communication c'est un projet
passionnant et nous espérons participe
évidemment au prochain
oui vous dire a priori ces îles sont là
alors la réponse est oui évidemment là
du fait qu' on travaille avec eux il ya
aussi le côté amateur et quel côté les
il ya le côté plaisir aussi moi moi
j'ajouterai juste que on a récupéré plus
de 7 millions de tram avec le satellite
actuellement en orbite qui est quand
même une pleine réussite quand on
regarde historiquement par rapport au
nombre de petits satellites qui ont été
mis en orbite donc on a réussi quelque
chose qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
d'exceptionnel il ya aussi une part de
réussite faut pas non plus et concernant
la réception des données ce sont tous
les radioamateurs dans le monde qui
récupère les données donc au delà des
clubs français ou francophones nous
avons aussi le support des radioamateurs
dans le monde entre dans le monde entier
et c'est à ce moment faut être très très
fort en maths pour être radio matin
alors on dit que l'examen en france qui
est un peu difficile c'est le niveau de
première en physique d'accord voilà donc
c'est comme c'est acceptable mais le le
niveau est assez élevée dans d'autres
pays il ya plusieurs niveaux il a une
licence novice très facile à voir et
d'autres niveaux
mais donc c'est quand même de la
physique évidemment des mathématiques ok
bah merci beaucoup perdre me questionner
avec louvre on va aborder maintenant les
enjeux scientifiques et on va recevoir
jean paul le cartable decarta rouxel on
regarde d'abord les des anges de
scientifiques merci beaucoup pire le
caso et et prévoit la vie voilà la
deuxième mission
rubik's cube uvs qu sat est doté d'une
multitude de capteurs hérité des progrès
technologiques de la miniaturisation
pour mesurer les trois termes du bilan
radiatif de la terre
le rayonnement solaire arrivant sur la
terre le rayonnement solaire réfléchie
par la terre et le rayonnement
infrarouge émis par la terre
ce petit concentré de technologie de
pointe permet ainsi de recueillir des
informations importantes sur le bilan
radiatif de la terre à savoir l'énergie
qu'elle gagne ou qu'elle perde notamment
à l'échelle régionale
cette collecte s'effectue par la mesure
durant moins une année de ces trois
termes de rayonnement pour valider le
principe de cette miniaturisation en vue
du déploiement d'une constellation
hétérogène de petits satellites
d'autre part la mission réalise
également des mesures très délicate du
rayonnement solaire dans le domaine de
l'ultraviolet dont la variabilité
impactent directement l'ozone et la
température dans la moyenne atmosphère
de la terre et pourraient ainsi
influencer la météorologie de la basse
atmosphère à l'échelle régionale
enfin cette mission permet de tester un
dispositif médical de prévention de la
santé des astronautes par le biais du
programme cheechoo r ce dernier doit
permettre à terme de préserver leur
santé avec des outils de diagnostic et
des dallas décision en situation
complexe durant des missions de longue
durée par exemple vers mars
ubs qu sat est ainsi le premier
laboratoire de vol de ce capteur placé
sous la responsabilité de la société
cartes ar hawks elle est pilotée par le
latmos grâce à son savoir-faire spatiale
alors petit chou rc vous jean paul carta
bonjour vous êtes tels le bois zone
carta rouxel qui est une entreprise de
mécanique de précision
mais petit choix c'est un gilet 1 c'est
ça c'est ça tout
gilles est connecté et qui permet de
regarder si on a une bonne position
rossa en fait c'est ça c'est pour vous
monitorer puis pour vous apprendre à
maintenir la meilleure des positions
possibles pour ne pas être altéré par un
mal de dos que tout le monde connaît et
nous avons eu la chance d'être invité à
bord de la mission ubs q7 pour une
vision plutôt médicaux spatiale de nos
travaux alors pardon je pose une
question un peu de béotiens mais on se
dit un gilet bon c'est bien pour pour un
astronaute quoi quelques cris monde en
l'espace de deux rives excuses sa part
pas battu y'a pas y'a pas de nier pas
d'astronaute alors en fait c'est une
première étape il a fallu un peu comme
si on passait son permis de conduire
passé par cet esthète étape pardon
comment dire incontournable qui nous
permet de valider un ensemble je sais
pas si on peut voir tibari voilà il a
fallu passer par un ensemble
d'opérations alors comment maîtriser
cette 10e son décès le coffret le
coffret qui a été validé pour pouvoir
enfermé notre capteur qui a été fabriqué
à la fois par notre société et le centre
d'investigation clinique de l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches qui nous a
permis de mettre la technologie du
titulaire du vêtement pour les personnes
en situation de handicap ou les salariés
et bien de miniaturiser et de pouvoir le
loger dans ce coffret d'accord c'est un
petit coffret de ce à quoi c'est juste
ça rien et pendant un an bien voilà
aujourd'hui nous fêtons nous un an nous
avons donc validé à la fois notre
concept puisqu'il fonctionne il donne de
la donne et sauvage et en plus il a
validé l'ensemble des matériaux utilisés
ce qui fait que maintenant je vais
pouvoir envisager grâce à mes
partenaires allez sur l'étape suivante
qui est celle de
comment dire poursuivre l'aventuré avec
les spationautes de demain vers des
voyages beaucoup plus long et leur
assurer un maintien dorsale et peut-être
d'autres choses en plus pour leur santé
le petit frère il existe déjà alors le
teacher est en train d'être développé au
sein du laboratoire d'étude en
mécatronique et mobilité qui est au sein
de l'ue vs but qui est aussi notre grand
partenaire et c'est un projet qui est
validé par l' agence nationale de la
recherche sur un laps comme entre nous
entreprise privée et institutionnelle le
public et donc nous arrivons à voile a
amené des projets aussi fou que celui ci
et qui aujourd'hui nous amène à cette
petite réussite dont on est très fiers
et ça va servir allah vous disiez aux
gens qui vont partir dans l'espace mais
mais mais ça peut servir tout le monde
ça peut servir aux personnes handicapées
aussi en fait nous nous servons de ce
levier qui est le monde spatial pour
pouvoir justement faire des retombées
thérèse parce qu'on oublie souvent que
tout ce qui est fait dans l'espace n'est
pas fait que pour prendre de belles
photos c'est fait pour deux meilleures
équipes des ligues mais il y à dents sur
le plan de la recherche il ya
d'innombrables données qui sont
recueillies sur terre et qui permettent
de faire avancer la médecine la
technologie la mécanique est donc voilà
comment une petite structure yvelinoise
aujourd'hui est en train de monter en
puissance sur ce domaine là c'est
important pour une entreprise comme vous
un as et très important ça a été une
aventure extraordinaire on nous a
laissés 18 mois pour devenir spécialiste
d'un lancement
quand on est entouré des gens comme le
latmos et du vs cuba c'est un vrai
plaisir même s'il ya beaucoup de
contraintes c'est un milieu dans lequel
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi ça
oblige aussi une société comme la nôtre
à se remettre en question et à aborder
l'avenir avec de nouvelles questions et
puis les équipes s'y sont totalement
investis l'hôpital de garches qui est
aujourd'hui notre plus grand partenaire
et est aujourd'hui avec nous à la tête
de nombreux projets voilà dont vous
entendrez parler dans quelques mois
philippe excuses c'est justement une des
particularités de cette vision c'est
cette coopération entre le public et le
privé
bientôt important et on le voit bien
aidé c'est vrai que les scientifiques
sont souvent à la pointe de ces
initiatives mais mais aujourd'hui on
voit bien que là le besoin sociétal fait
qu' il faut travailler sur la
convergence alors convergence de deux
façons la convergence d'une part de
partage des outils puisqu'on voit bien
que finalement un outil peut servir là à
la recherche pure de l'atmosphère mais
mais mais à d'autres domaines et là on
parle effectivement d'un domaine qui
encore recherche aussi même s'il a plein
d'applications donc on voit qu'il ya une
convergence et puis après la convergence
elle est aussi on l'a dit financière et
et les outils peuvent être partagées
donc là il ya un aspect économique de la
recherche qui fait que on ne finance pas
la recherche d'un côté puis il recherche
appliquée de l'autre l'autre on cherche
à trouver comment on peut trouver des
synergies qui vont nous permettre de
baisser les coûts de tout ce qu'on fait
et du coup de multiplier les expériences
et les capacités de deux tests et de et
d'emport il ya eu d'autres entreprises
comme carlier je voulais juste rajouter
si vous permettez que c'est aussi une
affaire de territoire c'est aubry
comment s'accaparer des technologies que
l'on pensait pas forcément être à notre
portée et s'est avéré que quand une
entreprise comme la nôtre est bien
entouré on arrive à monter en puissance
à apprendre on devient on est apprenti
un jour apprentis toujours pour le coup
et c'est vrai que nous avons besoin nous
maintenant d'un apport massif des dalles
à part de la part de nos institutions de
notre gouvernement pour permettre à des
petits trucs comme ou d'évoluer de créer
de l'emploi et de perspectives vous avez
combien d'employés alors non il ya des
pme purement française un très petites
entreprises moins de 10 salariés
entreprise familiale qui aujourd'hui est
en train de prendre une orientation un
peu différente et voient arriver vers
elle des gens qui ont besoin d'un
certain savoir faire donc nous nous
avons aussi l'obligation de maintenir et
de pouvoir répondre voilà très
rapidement parce que nous sommes petits
donc agile rapide et facile de
compréhension pour des interlocuteurs
qui ont une multitude d'acteurs et bien
aujourd'hui avec des structures comme la
nôtre c'est beaucoup plus rapide de mise
en oeuvre et là vous donnons la prendre
à votre question la concernant les
industriels donc évidemment on a
travaillé avec jean d'autres oui nous
avons d'autres andriel de l'entreprise
on favorise évidemment toutes les
entreprises qui sont de proximité dans
le territoire on est toujours dans cette
crise sanitaire et l' avantage de la
stratégie que nous avons mise en place
c'est que comme nous étions dans des
circuits courts nous n'avons pas été
trop bloqués donc on s'est retrouvé dans
une solution qui est très intéressante à
ce niveau là un autre point qui importe
en moi je tiens à soulever c'est que le
new space révolutionne le monde spatial
aujourd'hui l'espace fait rêver il fait
aussi rêver je pense les investisseurs
et donc on a besoin nous d'être avec eux
et de
trouver des solutions alors typiquement
pour ce capteur de santé vous allez vous
dire pourquoi on a mis ce capteur de
santé dans le satellite eh ben on va
l'utiliser en applications duales donc
les besoins de jean-paul ont été
clairement exprimées mais nous on l'a
utilisé différemment la première chose
c'est est de qualifier en orbite ce
composant le valider oui de le
spatialisé le moment mais nous derrière
ce qu'on fait avec aussi c'est que quand
vous prenez par exemple un satellite qui
en orbite il ne manque qu'une brique
actuellement c'est de maîtriser
l'attitude du satellite typiquement
aussi un ami philippe et le soleil je
dois pouvoir pointer vers le soleil donc
il ya une brique de pointage d'un
satellite donc l'intérêt pour nous mais
vis-à-vis de ce capteur c'est de
l'utiliser en applications duales et de
s'en servir comme dispositif de pointage
d'accord oui c'était dangereux surprise
ça c'est quelque chose qui a très très
bien fonctionné en or 10 duels ça veut
dire c'est un de zone
et sa pièce de viande il voit qu'il a
une double utilité c'est incroyable
c'est une grande fierté et puis ça nous
a permis aussi de se projeter avec
beaucoup plus d'affirmations dans notre
volonté de nous orienter vers le spatial
puisque nous nous sommes aperçus que non
seulement nous répondions aux exigences
de notre laboratoire et en plus nous
avions cette perspective qui s'ouvre à
nous de pouvoir maintenir notre
collaboration avec lui vs qu est le
latmos pour de futures missions je
tenais juste aussi à remercier pour
nombre d'écoles qui nous ont aidés
notamment sur des outils de maquettes il
ya eu vraiment si vous voulez sur tout
le territoire d'île de france on peut le
dire il ya une implication qui allait
au-delà de la volonté d'un chef et de
chefs d'entreprises on a eu des
responsables d'écoles qui nous ont aidés
d'université d'iut même de collège qui
ont pris ça à leur compte donc voila
c'était une aventure qui dépasse
largement le cas de ce que l'on pouvait
espérer car times elle s'est installée
ou le ciel alors nous sommes à
gargenville donc nous sommes vraiment
sur l'ouest parisien et ne sommes pas
loin des mureaux qui est aussi nous
c'est un endroit où nous y avons si nos
laboratoires et c'est aussi la capitale
européenne on peut le dire du spatial
puisque j'ai été formé à l'âge de 15 ans
à l'aérospatiale
toujours ce lien
évitez de man qui a eu des demandes
voilà pourquoi il m'a seulement parce qu
est ce qu on a une formation aussi
mécatronique et spatiales licence a été
créé d'ailleurs la halle pessimistes qui
est donc là bas donc c'est aussi une
grande fierté que notre territoire
l'ouest parisien est toujours un peu vu
je savais un peu trop cul-terreux pour
les parisiens je ne peux rien donc voilà
bien là on a pu montrer que ce
territoire à bercy dans un territoire
d'innovation à ses forces ne serait-ce
que les yvelines c'est vrai
quand vous dites que vous avez 10
salariés le vous aimeriez grandir alors
nous aimerions grandir mais
grandir aujourd'hui est très compliquée
par la conjoncture et tout ça et nous
avons aussi un défi à relever c'est sûr
la perte des compétences sont des
métiers qui ont été fortement abandonné
pendant 30 ans et aujourd'hui on a du
mal à trouver des gens qualifiés et
alors ce sont les métiers qui offrent de
très belles perspectives pour les
salariés les jeunes donc on aimerait
redorer un peu
le blason je dirais de ces métiers
nobles et on travaille beaucoup avec les
universités avec la chambre de commerce
et de l'industrie et d'autres acteurs
importants du territoire pour redorer le
blason faut pas oublier que le l'ouest
parisien était un territoire très riche
à l'automobile le spatial et donc depuis
trente ans on a bien vu ce détricotage
industriels et aujourd'hui c'est un vrai
problème pour nous pour trouver des
salariés avaient des qualifications un
vrai problème en ce sens c'est important
de le dire ça près
merci beaucoup jean-paul cas cela on va
enfin on va aborder maintenant l'avenir
et
et on va recevoir benjamin azoulay qui
est un autre industriel qui va
participer à cette deuxième mission et
l'avenir s'il s'appelle aspire ça tu
sais tu
imaginé par des chercheurs du cnrs
inspired 7 est un anneau satellite
français principalement dédié à
l'observation de la terre ce nouveau
programme spatial s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la mission uvs qu sat
[Musique]
le développement lancement et la gestion
en orbite d'un anneau satellite par
l'équipe du latmos membre à part entière
de l'eau vs cul et de son université de
rattachement représente l'aboutissement
d'un long processus porté par une vision
qui remonte à plus d'une vingtaine
d'années les premiers résultats
scientifiques obtenus avec le
démonstrateur uvs cul ça tu montre
l'intérêt de mettre en oeuvre une
constellation d'une centaine de petits
satellites dédiés à l'étude du climat
porté par le new space et respectueux du
traité de l'espace de 1967 ce projet de
constellation de satellites ayant pour
vocation l'étude de l'environnement
global de la terre et du climat devient
possible
si rien n'est fait pour limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
réchauffement climatique pourrait
atteindre + 6 degrés celsius d'ici à la
fin du siècle ce qui entraînerait des
conséquences désastreuses pour les
espèces et les écosystèmes
il est plus que nécessaire de développer
de réelles stratégies de lutte contre
les émissions de co2 et d'adaptation aux
dérèglements climatiques
surveillez la terre depuis l'espace fait
aussi partie de la solution avec une
constellation de satellites il est
possible d'observer ces changements avec
un niveau de détail sans précédent en
termes d'échelle spatiale et temporelle
inspired 7 cherchera aussi à mettre en
orbite le premier module wifi à bord
d'un cube sat oled comme et le latmos
souhaite ainsi démontrer que la
communication sans fil basés sur la
lumière est une alternative crédible au
harnais de cuivre traditionnels
que ce soit d'un point de vue de la
masse ou de l'ingénierie le lift y offre
des perspectives intéressantes pour les
applications spatiales de demain
alors on va parler de cet aspect 7 7
mais on accueille déjà mazoutés vous
êtes donc le président paul ii comme
entreprise spécialisée le lit fille
alors on en a parlé un petit peu
l'édifice et c'est la communication sans
fil d'un saint c'est ça c'est la
communication sans fil qui utilise de la
lumière c'est à dire des photons pour
communiquer au lieu d'utiliser des
radiofréquences alors c'est ça a
beaucoup d'intérêt en matière de
sécurité notamment parce que la lumière
ne va pas traverser les murs donc dans
certaines applications extrêmement
sensible en matière de cybersécurité le
lift y est très intéressant notamment
toutes les applications les ondes
radiofréquences sont interdites nous on
a une solution alors ce qui s'est passé
avec le lit fils et qu'il y a deux ans
le cnes nous a contactés pour faire un
premier prototype pour remplacer du
câble à l'intérieur de de la fusée
ariane c'est comme ça que notre histoire
a commencé on s'est posé la question
comment faire pour prouver que notre
technologie puisse voler et c'est là que
inspired seven est arrivé d'accord ah
oui c'était cette question
vous êtes le stylet ou alors nous sommes
à vélizy annoncé nous sommes une société
qui issus de laboratoires universitaires
à deluz facebook et donc c'est tout
naturellement que nous avions d
appétence particulière avec
avec le monde universitaire et
académique moustapha pourquoi pourquoi
c'est important cette opération dans le
spice est incertain déjà c'est qu'on
reste connecté avec les industriels il
avait vu que sur la précédente mission
on avait travaillé que la société carta
rouxel monde embarque une charge utile
avec qui on travaille on les haines on
fait aussi du transfert de compétences
ou de savoir-faire on réalise la même
chose vis-à-vis des armes des solutions
sans fil on a trouvé on a trouvé que la
la charge utile de l'aide comme était
intéressante parce qu'on en a plusieurs
propositions plusieurs industriels on a
trouvé que ce qu'il nous proposait
c'était vraiment le plus intéressant
donc on en souhaitait les embarquer
travailler avec eux parce que dans les
satellites et notamment les petits
satellites il ya énormément de harnais
électriques
ça produit de la masse ça alourdit les
systèmes ça complexifie les intégrations
donc on pense que il y a un potentiel
économique et comme je vous expliquais
on est dans une stratégie de new space
on doit aussi donner la chance aux
petites entreprises et aux moyennes
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
démontrer les choses parce que en gros
les idées d'aujourd'hui à demain elles
seront mises en place et on pense que
oled comme et cette technique naturelle
presque
servait la vidéo aurait tendance à dire
là je parle juste d'une question vachin
résout les lie arrivée d'amorcer cette
expérimentation dans l'espace avec un
satellite mais dans la vie de tous les
jours le lit fils
s'était déjà utilisé wee cc déjà utilisé
par les armées notamment pour passer
cccc le sans fil de manière ultra
sécurisé d'accord les armées n'ont
souvent pas le droit d'utiliser de wifi
vous savez qu'il faut 17 secondes pour
atteindre wifi donc c'est pas du tout
suffisamment sécurisé donc donc quand on
veut avoir du sans fil parce que le film
les filets rapporte énormément de
contraintes impact l'environnement de
façon assez lourde nous on a une
solution trop on a également aidé
entreprises peuvent se laisser guider
sur des entreprises qui ont une certaine
sensibilité à la cybersécurité on a
également et équiper des écoles
a commencé à équiper des crèches des
écoles maternelles nous étions salon
educatec beaucoup de départements de
collectivités territoriales qui sont
intéressés par la solution là c'est plus
pour l'aspect sans ondes puisque vous
savez qu'en france on a pas le droit d
d'exposer des enfants de moins de 3 ans
aux ondes radio dans l'est dans les
lieux publics voilà alors veut dans un
aspect 7,7 en principe le lancement
c'est quoi ces 2023 2023 en principe
voilà tout à fait et là on espère
effectivement alors le nouveau satellite
la ilaha illa deux fonctions il a d'une
part
démontré le volant constellation 1 donc
on espère pouvoir voir les deux
satellites pour montrer ce que j'apporte
de satellites par provincial et donc
peut-être demain une constellation
encore plus grande et une constellation
ça veut dire jusqu'à combien de
satellites après tout tout dépend de ce
qu'on est capable de faire 1 on dirait
que l'idéal être entre 10 et 100 with
their que jusqu'à pas me corrigera les
constellations industriels existent déjà
parce que on voit apparaître une
privatisation de l'espace donc si vous
regardez par exemple spectre x avec sa
constellation starlink vous avez plus de
2000 satellite vous prenez wan web c'est
pareil donc le privé présent donc au
niveau scientifique ou au niveau de la
recherche il ya des intérêts et biz
habib aspire sats est évidemment c'est
de pouvoir valider deux satellites en
orbite pour voir comment diagonalistes
l'information scientifique
alors il ya un autre paramètre aussi
c'est que on a mis une modification avec
un nouvel industriel qui a impliqué avec
nous dans la mission mais dans inspire
sa tête on va aussi s'intéresser à autre
chose c'est à la ionosphère c'est à dire
alors un la noce faire peut-être leur
expliqué philippe rapidement oui alors
c'est vrai que c'est une région qui est
assez hautain on a une atmosphère assez
homogène qui diminue mais assez homogène
jusqu'à 80 100 km et puis au dessus on a
une atmosphère qui continue mais qui est
beaucoup plus diffusés et un peu
différente avec des la physique assez
différente mais qui reste quand même
très très importante pour pour notre
atmosphère justement pour ces questions
aussi de deux de transfert dont radio 2
et puis de tout ce qui est qui vient de
l'extérieur c'est là où on a le champ
magnétique aussi qui nous protège donc
il se passe beaucoup de choses hein les
aurores boréales et donc donc c'est ça
fait quand même partie de l'atmosphère
et donc aujourd'hui
on a besoin de s'intéresser aux liens et
notamment cette région elle est aussi
très importante pour ce qu'on appelle le
space weather puisque c'est dans cette
région là où évoluent les satellites et
donc vont rencontrer d une atmosphère
qui doivent savoir gérer c'est là où
effectivement le soleil va va
effectivement
il ya par des orages magnétiques etc qui
peuplent qui peuvent perturber dockal
est très importante aussi cette région
est donc là on travaille avec l'onera
sur 7 sur ses pieds
alors l'onera
cccc d'eau coule l'organisme national de
recherche en
sur l'aérospatiale et raciales et donc
qui est localisée à plusieurs endroits
en france mais notamment on discute
beaucoup avec nos partenaires de
palaiseau et du coup là aussi il ya des
questions que l'on partage et du coup il
ya des charges utiles voilà qu'on va on
a développé avec eux pour comprendre
cette partie est du coup ce qui nous
intéresse aussi c'est de comprendre ce
lien entre la ionosphère et est ce qu'on
appelle la moyenne de bosse père qui
nous concerne plus est de savoir
activement sur le climat et du coup la
prime en sommeil à l'affluence sur le
climat mais il ya aussi le lien avec la
propagation des ondes notamment dans
l'atmosphère et ça c'est fondamental
parce que si on a une perte de
communication de satellites on a besoin
de mieux comprendre ces propagation
alors mon collègue a parlé de space
weather mais pour le grand public c'est
la métérologie de l'espace une de nos
inquiétudes c'est typiquement on peut
avoir des orages des éjections de masse
coronale d'origine solaire et ça ça peut
perturber énormément les satellites donc
comme nous sommes dans un monde hyper
technologique
avec une multitude de satellites en
avait beaucoup de cette élite
jamais on perd ses satellites c'est très
problématique pour nous en terme de
communication il faut savoir pouvoir les
récupérer un ça va il anticipe et des
effets son pouvoir arrêter ou couper les
satellites mais on a besoin
d'informations donc l'enjeu et
l'observation spatiale c'est quelque
chose de clé dans la vie de tous les
jours et pour nos affaires
le premier set est listé uvsq us atlas à
sa peine spy 1 et spy c'est un
consortium de deux enfants vous n'êtes
pas tout salarié je crois qu'il ya des
iai à singapour y est des états unis il
ya taïwan alors ça c'est un consortium
que que l'on a
co créé avec l'ailé nos partenaires
universitaires qui ont un peu la même
démarche c'est à dire qui qui qui ont
voilà cette vision de recherche
cette division aussi pédagogique puisque
tous les partenaires la fois intervenir
des étudiants éventuellement échanges d
étudiants et du coup il ya un échange de
connaissances et donc inspire ça tu sais
tu sais tu sais c'est le septième dans
la pile de de ce qu'on a partagé avec
eux d'accord et voilà et donc du coup
bien évidemment notamment pour pour
pouvoir valider toute la démarche on a
des comités scientifiques qui se
réunissent et des comités internationaux
avec du coup nos partenaires qui nous
dit qu'ils nous critique qui nous alerte
sur des choses qu'on n'a peut-être pas
pris en compte pour que à la fin malgré
tout on soit quasi sûr que notre système
qui fonctionne c'est ça l'objectif vous
parliez des étudiants c'est important
quand même d'en dire un mot parce que
c'est aussi tu vas toutes ces
expériences là ce sont aussi des
expériences importantes pour pour
l'enseignement et pour la formation tout
à fait alors il ya plusieurs plusieurs
parties c'est à dire que d'une part ces
projets là
sont pilotés voilà par des
professionnels mais on intègre le plus
possible des étudiants pour qu'ils
comprennent finalement en pratique ce
que cette le spatial et ses oeuvres ses
projets qui se font assez rapidement par
rapport je dirais à des projets plus
traditionnels et plus importants
permettent vraiment une intervention des
étudiants et puis après on a également
la formation initiale c'est à dire qu on
en a parlé tout à l'heure mise en place
d'une licence pro qui permet
effectivement mécatronique et spatiale
de 2,2 pour pour ceux qui travaillent
sur la mécatronique de voir comment on
l'appliqué spatiale et puis il ya un
nouveau master qui se fait dans le cadre
de paris saclay qui s'appelle le master
new space 1 pour les nouvelles
applications alors là l'idée c'est
effectivement de voir l'ensemble de la
chaîne du concept à la réception de
données pour bien identifier où sont les
enjeux et les problèmes pour pour avoir
une vision un peu transverses donc c'est
un peu une nouvelle formation qui
devrait amener effectivement
d'une part de fournir des étudiants
voilà aux sociétés qui disent se met
assez assez assez nouveau concept et
puis éventuellement certains la
recherche aussi et vous sentez que vous
sentez une sorte d'apothéose comme ça
que c'est les étudiants pour la pour
l'espace pour la recherche s'est passé
assez clair c'est ce qu'a dit moustafa
sais c'est un domaine qui qui qui a tiré
le même comme un levain et puis et est
du coup et qui est qui et qui a et qui
peut amener à autre chose est-ce que les
gens bien se former sur cette
technologie là et puis après partir sur
des on l'a bien vu sur des aspects de
télécoms sur des aspects voilà de 2,2 de
transfert de données sur des aspects
après de techno qui peut s'appliquer à
la voiture aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
convergences dans beaucoup de domaines
donc du coup l'idée cc voilà c'est cet
actif froid actif pouvoir pouvoir
effectivement évolué d'un milieu à un
autre mais il faut il faut il faut
acquérir quand même côté pratique et
nous c'est ce qu'on peut offrir à
l'université aussi on a on a quand même
des installations de tout premier plan
qui permettent aux étudiants de se
former vraiment aux outils
pour une entreprise alors vous disiez
vous devenez presque d'univers de
l'université voyez les délires mais
c'est important justement la formation
des étudiants pour des entreprises comme
vous c'est même très très important vous
savez aujourd'hui il est très difficile
de trouver des ingénieurs des
électroniciens c'est ce qu'on dit qu'ils
en sortent ils et c'est vrai que moi je
considère comme un atout fabuleux pour
l'entreprise d'être encore au sein du
monde académique d'avoir des relations
avec les professeurs qui nous envoient
des étudiants et on arrive grâce à ça
même pour une petite entreprise de façon
assez miraculeuse à avoir des ressources
et des compétences
très pointues que parfois des grandes
entreprises n'arrivent pas avoir par ces
papas par cette proximité qu'on a gardé
avec le monde académique paul ii comme
en dehors de la validation des défis que
le wifi peut marcher dans l'espace
qu'elle est quel est l'enjeu ou faut
pour vous là écoutez nous notre vision
c'est que
on va pouvoir fournir au monde une
connectivité sans fil partout les ondes
radiofréquences pose un problème donc
c'est une c'est un marché de niche mais
qui pète en fait un gros marché de niche
quand on s'aperçoit que pas mal de
domaines où les ondes radiofréquences ne
sont pas désirées sont parfois prohibée
nous on apporte une solution sans fil
m'apporte le sans fil dans ces
environnements là vous voilà un peu
notre notre vision on est
on s'est positionné sur plusieurs
marchés le marché de l'aéro et du
spatial on a aussi fait l'aéronautique
on a été le premier première entreprise
au monde à l'équipage un avion d'air
france 2 le siège passager ce qu'on
gagne du poids grâce à cette technologie
le spatial la défense les transports et
l'automobile pour faire de la
communication de véhicule
infrastructures à très grande vitesse et
donc l'éducation comme j'avais
et exprimer un peu plus tôt là c'est
plus pour 200 ondes pour pour pour les
enfants en bas âge voilà si on devait
dire parce qu'on arrive malheureusement
à la fin de l'émission b
vous font les leçons vous tiré de duvet
ce qu'ils savent d'abord est ce qu on a
appris des choses alors oui on a appris
énormément de choses parce que on était
sur des programmes où parfois on avait
peut-être perdu un certain savoir faire
donc on repousse et on est à fond sur
l'idée de réappropriation moi j'aurais
tendance à dire on a mis en place une
philosophie avec un retour aux origines
dire que l'ère spatiale commence en 1957
mais quelque part on est partis puisé
notre inspiration dans le passé donc on
fait quelque chose de très simple on
tente on teste pour corriger et on peut
accepter potentiellement l'échec pour
pouvoir mieux corriger c'est important
et aller vers quelque chose de différent
et ce qui est très important pour nous
en lien avec notamment les étudiants
c'est que comme on est dans des process
cours on leur montre rapidement une
chaîne de a à z et size adore parce que
on a les étudiants qui ont besoin de
voir de matérialiser et comme
l'enseignement bon a besoin aussi de ses
outils selon un outil concret un visuel
et ça ça les passionne complètement on
les attendait dans le concret vrai dans
la et un mot sur l'espace au fond on
revoit qu'elle ait yalla cohabitation de
deux dojos il ya des vols habités qui
repartent et puis il ya ces nano
satellites enfin cette presque cette
démocratisation de l'espace sais pas si
on peut appeler ça comme ça cette
cohabitation elle est importante
oui comme je le disais c'est une
question de convergence et de travailler
tous ensemble aujourd'hui on voit bien
la recherche doit s'appuyer la recherche
bien évidemment aujourd'hui on arrive à
faire sortir de l'université un certain
nombre de technologies
en fait mais la démonstration mais on a
encore beaucoup de mal à travailler au
quotidien avec les entreprises y est
donc là il ya un espace à inventer
on est en train de toucher du doigt le
fait de au quotidien
avoir d'une part les entreprises qui
font les applications et puis la
recherche qui s'appuie sur les outils
parce qu'on a besoin des mêmes outils
pour faire pour faire la recherche
fondamentale et puis tout ça pour les
étudiants aussi j'ai fait les formes et
les générations futures et
se frotter aux nouvelles technologies
merci infiniment
eh bien d'abord je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion de se revoir avant le
lancement des spas 7,7 bravo parce que
c'est quand même une magnifique réussite
pour le latmos pour lui a exclu pour le
territoire pour les entreprises
puis on croise les doigts pour le pour
l'avenir merci infiniment
[Musique]